.
WE'LL MONITOR IT FOR BREAKING
NEWS.
YOU CAN WATCH IT ON
FOXNEWS.COM/STREAM.
THE SUPREME COURT WITH A RULING
THAT WILL ROCK BLUE STATES FROM
COAST TO COAST.
THE NATION'S HIGHEST COURT
TOSSING OUT NEW YORK STATE'S
RESTRICTIVE REGULATIONS ON
CONCEAL PERMITS, AND SAYING
AMERICAN HAVE A LEGAL RIGHT TO
CARRY FIREARMS IN PUBLIC.
THE BOMBSHELL RULING COULD
SPREAD TO OTHER BLUE STATES LIKE
CALIFORNIA.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAID NEW YORK
LEADERS FURIOUS AND LASHING OUT.
>> TODAY THE SUPREME COURT IS
SENDING US BACKWARDS IN OUR
EFFORTS TO PROTECT FAMILIES AND
PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE.
SHOCKING.
ABSOLUTELY SHOCKING.
I'M SORRY THIS DARK DAY HAS.
>> THIS DECISION HAS MADE EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF US LESS SAFE FROM
GUN VIOLENCE.
WE CANNOT ALLOW NEW YORK TO
BECOME THE WILD, WILD WEST.
>> WE, THE PRESIDENT, MYSELF,
MANY OF US ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED
AND TROUBLED BY THE SUPREME
COURT'S RULING TODAY.
IT DEFIES COMMON SENSE.
AND THE CONSTITUTION.
>> THE FACT THAT THE COURT IS
COMING DOWN WITH THIS DECISION
FEELS TONE-DEAF.
I WORRY THAT IT UNDERMINES THE
LEGITIMACY OF THE COURT.
>> I'M DISAPPOINTED IN THE
SUPREME COURT GUN DECISION.
I THINK IT'S A BAD DECISION.
I THINK IT'S NOT REASONED
ACCURATELY.
I'M DISAPPOINTED.
>> AND THE LADIES OF "THE VIEW"
ARE TAKING THEIR OUTRAGE TO A
WHOLE NEW LEVEL.
>> I DON'T HAVE THE WORDS.
IT SEEMS STUPID.
>> NO.
IT'S WORSE THAN THAT.
>> IT'S A DEATH WISH.
>> NO.
IT'S SUCH A MIDDLE FINGER TO NEW
YORK.
>> OH, JEEZ.
>> JUDGE, WHAT DO YOU THINK THE
CHANCES ARE THAT WHOOPI GOLDBERG
READ ANY OF THE OPINION?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, I'D PROBABLY
WAGER MY HOUSE ON THAT ONE.
I REALLY WOULD.
I GOT TO TELL YOU, THIS DECISION
BY THE UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT IS A FULL-THROATED DEFENSE
OF THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
THE SUPREME COURT IS BASICALLY
SAYING THIS IS A CONSTITUTIONAL
SECOND AMENDMENT THAT IS
EXPLICIT FOR ALL OF THOSE
CONCERNED ABOUT ROE, TRYING TO
WORK IT IN, IMPLICIT, AND IT'S
DRAWN IN AND INTERPRETED, THIS
IS EXPLICIT, WHERE THEY
BASICALLY SAY YOU, NEW YORK
STATE, YOU CANNOT ADD ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS.
IF SOMEONE WANTS A HANDGUN OR
REVOLVER, THEY COME AND GET
PERMISSION FOR THAT, YOU GIVE
THEM THAT PERMISSION, YOU CANNOT
THEN SAY TO THEM, BY THE WAY, IF
YOU WANT TO CARRY THIS GUN, THEN
YOU HAVE TO SHOW A SPECIAL NEED.
THE SPECIAL NEED TO THEM IS SOME
CIRCUMSTANCE WERE YOU IN
PARTICULAR ARE SUBJECTED TO SOME
KIND OF -- OF -- OF -- OF CRIME
OR OFFENSE.
THE SUPREME COURT SAID NO,
THERE'S NO SECOND TEST.
THERE'S ONLY THE FIRST STATE.
46 STATES REQUIRE YOU TO GET A
LICENSE TO CARRY A GUN.
THEY SAID THAT'S FINE.
BUT YOU DON'T GO TO LEVEL TWO,
AND SAY, NOW, IF YOU WANT TO
CARRY IT, YOU HAVE TO PROVE XY
AND Z.
THE TWO GUYS WHO BROUGHT UP THIE
GUYS EXPERIENCED IN CARRYING
GUNS, USING GUNS.
ONE LIVED IN A NEIGHBORHOOD
WHERE THERE WERE A LOT OF
ROBBERIES.
JUSTICE THOMAS SAID THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE SECOND AMENDMENT
THAT DRAWS A HOME PUBLIC
DISTINCTION WITH RESPECT TO THE
RIGHT TO BEAR IN TERMS.
WHAT'S INCREDIBLE, IN TERMS OF
NEW YORK -- THIS IS A QUOTE FROM
THE DECISION -- THE RESPONDENT'S
ATTEMPT TO CHARACTERIZE NEW
YORK'S PROPER CAUSE
REQUIREMENT -- THAT MEANS YOU
HAVE TO SHOW MORE REASON TO HAVE
A GUN -- AS A SENSITIVE PLACE
LACKS TOTAL MERIT, BECAUSE
THERE'S NO HISTORICAL BASIS FOR
NEW YORK TO EFFECTIVELY DECLARE
THE ISLAND OF MANHATTAN A
SENSITIVE PLACE SIMPLY BECAUSE
IT'S CROWDED AND PROTECTED
GENERALLY BY THE NEW YORK CITY
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
SO THAT'S THE ANSWER TO MAYOR
ERIC ADAMS, WHO IS SO OUTRAGED.
WHY ARE THE LIBERALS SO OUTRAGED
BY THE CRIMINALS CARRYING THE
ILLEGAL GUNS?
THEY'RE LETTING THEM OUT OF JAIL
TO HIT THE STREETS AGAIN AND
VICTIMIZE THE REST OF US.
ONE MORE QUOTE FROM THIS
DECISION, THEY SAY THAT THERE IS
IN THE UNITED STATES AN ENDURING
AMERICAN TRADITION THAT PERMITS
A PUBLIC CARRY.
SO DON'T EVEN QUESTION IT.
>> JUDGE MAKES THE POINT THAT
YOU DON'T HEAR KAMALA HARRIS OR
OTHER DEMOCRATS TALK ABOUT INNER
CITY SHOOTINGS.
THEY DON'T TALK ABOUT IT.
UNTIL TODAY.
NOW THEY'RE EXTREMELY CONCERNED
ABOUT IT, DANA.
>> AND SHE SAYS IT DOESN'T PASS
THE COMMON-SENSE TEST, AND THEN
ADDED OR THE CONSTITUTION.
JUSTICES SAY THAT IT DOES.
THE OTHER THING THAT'S HAPPENING
IS THAT PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T READ
THE OPINION, AND GAVE HOT TAKES,
AND THERE WERE SO MANY HOT
TAKES, IT WAS LIKE 150 DEGREES
OUTSIDE TODAY THERE WERE SO
MANY, THEY WEREN'T LOOKING AT
WHAT THE NARROW QUESTION WAS OF
THIS.
IT DIDN'T SAY THAT EVERYBODY NOW
ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU'RE GOING TO
BE HANDED -- GETTING A HANDGUN
LIKE YOU WERE A COVID TEST.
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING.
IT WAS VERY SPECIFIC.
IT WAS VERY NARROW.
I'LL TELL YOU THE GUN CONTROL
ADVOCATES SHOULD NEVER HAVE
PURSUED THIS.
FROM YEARS AGO, REMEMBER, I
REMEMBER LEARNING THAT, THEY
COULD LOSE IN THIS CASE.
IT TAKES A LONG TIME TO GET TO
THE SUPREME COURT.
NOW YOU HAVE THIS.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE MAYOR ADAMS
SAID WE WON'T HAVE ANY SLEEP.
WHY ARE THEY SO AFRAID OF
LAW-ABIDING PEOPLE?
THE JUDGE LAID OUT, YOU PASSED
THE BACKGROUND CHECK, PASSED A
TEST IN ORDER TO HAVE YOUR OWN
WEAPON.
ARE YOU ALLOWED TO TAKE IT WITH
YOU?
THAT'S THE ONLY QUESTION.
THEY ARE LAW-ABIDING PEOPLE.
THERE WILL BE MORE TO SAY ON
THIS.
THERE'S GREAT COMMENTARY.
YOU WANT TO READ SOMETHING THAT
WILL HELP YOU UNDERSTAND IT,
NATIONAL REVIEW HAS A GREAT
PIECE.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW DIFFICULT IT IS
TO GET A HANDGUN HERE IN NEW
YORK CITY.
>> I HAVE TO SAY, I'M GOING
THROUGH THE PROCESS.
IT WAS A PAIN IN THE NECK.
IT STILL IS.
A LOT OF IT HAD TO DO WITH THE
COVID STUFF.
EVERYTHING SHUT DOWN.
IT'S NOT ENTIRELY THE RED TAPE.
I HAD TO JUMP THROUGH A LOT OF
HOOPS.
YOU KNOW, WHEN MAYOR ADAMS SAYS
IT'S GOING TO BE A WILD, WILD
WEST, I CAN'T IMAGINE IT GETTING
WORSE THAN IT IS NOW, RIGHT?
I MEAN, IT'S LIKE WE GOT -- YOU
KNOW, WOULD YOU SAID, THEY'RE
NOT THAT UPSET ABOUT THE
LAWBREAKERS, THEY'RE MORE
WORRIED ABOUT THE LAW-ABIDING
PEOPLE.
I THINK ABOUT MASS SHOOTERS.
I DON'T BELIEVE -- SOMEONE CAN
CORRECT ME LATER.
I WON'T LISTEN.
BUT I DON'T BELIEVE ANYBODY WITH
A CONCEALED CARRY PERMIT EVER
COMMITTED A MASS SHOOTING.
AND SO I THINK THE BAN ITSELF
HAD NO ROLE IN, LIKE, PREVENTING
THESE THINGS, RIGHT?
BUT YOU COULD ARGUE THAT A
CONCEAL CARRY -- OR THAT COULD
HELP STOP A MASS SHOOTING
BECAUSE IT CREATES UNCERTAINTY
AMONG THE SUSPECTS.
THAT'S WHY THE AURORA SHOOTERS
SKIPPED A FEW MOVIE THEATERS
BECAUSE HE KNEW THERE WERE GUNS
THERE.
ALSO THE SCIENCE OF IT, THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE DYING IN A MASS
SHOOTING IS WHOLLY DEPENDENT ON
THE TIME IT TAKES FOR A GUN TO
GET THERE.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND GIVEN THE FACT THAT AT
THE LAST SHOOTING IN TEXAS THAT
THE POLICE HAD THE GUNS AND
DIDN'T DO IT, AND, BOY, DOES
THAT ARGUE FOR THIS, BECAUSE IF
THERE HAD BEEN A PERSON -- AND
THIS IS NOT TO CONDEMN THE
POLICE, BECAUSE THERE'S THE FOG
OF WAR ASPECT GOING ON, BUT IN
THIS FOG OF WAR THERE MIGHT BE
SOMEBODY WITHIN THAT WAR, THAT
ROOM, THAT MIGHT HAVE STOPPED
IT, AS OPPOSED TO THE PEOPLE OUT
THERE.
LAST WORD, HOCHUL HAS DONE
NOTHING TO CURB THE EPIDEMIC OF
CRIME IN THIS STATE.
SHE HAS NO RIGHT TO COMPLAIN
WHEN THE PUBLIC EMBRACES
SELF-PROTECTION AS A RIGHT.
THE FACT IS, YOU LET OUT REPEAT
DEFENDERS, YOU DEFUND, REDUCE
PENALTIES FOR GUN CRIME.
FORGIVE IF I'M GOING TO TURN MY
HOUSE INTO AN ARMED FORTRESS.
>> I DIFFER SLIGHTLY.
I THINK THE COURT, A 6-3
DECISION -- ROW WADE IS A 7-2
DECISION.
THE NUMBERS AROUND THE MAJORITY
ARE RELEVANT.
IF WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT IT
WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT ALL OF IT.
I ASK MYSELF A FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTION, JUDGE, AND YOU
PRESIDED AND PROSECUTED PEOPLE,
YOU FEEL SAFER TODAY KNOWING
THAT PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE
THEIR GUNS OUTSIDE THEIR HOMES,
WHO WE HOPE ARE SANE.
I HOPE EVERYONE WHO IS OUT JUST
TRYING TO PROTECT HIM OR
HERSELF.
I'M NOT SURE I FEEL SAFER.
I WOULD POSE THE QUESTION TO THE
TABLE, TOO.
I WONDER WHERE POLICE OFFICERS
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT ARE GOING TO
COME DOWN ON THIS.
WHEN I WAS IN COLLEGE, LAW
ENFORCEMENT ORGANIZATIONS DIDN'T
MIND COMMON-SENSE RESTRICTIONS,
BECAUSE THEY WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT CRIMINALS AND OTHERS.
AND UNDERSTAND, SOMEONE WHO'S
NOT A CRIMINAL TODAY WHO TAKES A
GUN AND USES IT FOR CRIMINAL
PURPOSES BECOMES A CRIMINAL
RIGHT AFTER THAT.
SO I HEAR ALL THE EXCITEMENT.
AGAIN, I'M NOT HERE TO POUR
WATER ON IT, BUT I'M HERE TO
OFFER A COUPLE QUESTIONS.
WHATEVER WE THINK ABOUT ADAMS,
WHATEVER WE THINK ABOUT THE
POLICE CHIEF, AND WHATEVER WE
BELIEVE ABOUT HOCHUL, I BELIEVE
THEY'RE TRYING TO MAKE THE CITY
SAFER.
THERE ARE MORE THINGS THEY
SHOULD BE DOING, BUT JUST
BECAUSE WE DON'T LIKE WHAT
THEY'RE DOING ELSEWHERE SHOULD
MEAN WE SHOULD SAY IT'S RIGHT
FOR THE CITY.
I'M JUST NOT CONVINCED THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO END UP.
AGAIN, I HOPE I'M WRONG.
>> THE ANSWER TO YOUR FIRST
QUESTION IS, THE QUESTION BEING
DO I FEEL SAFER, THAT'S NOT THE
TEST.
>> WE TALK ABOUT ISSUES, ISSUES
THAT IMPACT.
ONE OF THE PLAINTIFFS SAID,
LIKE, I WANT TO CARRY THIS GUN,
I LIVE IN A NEIGHBORHOOD, I HAVE
A NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE THERE'S
CRIME.
THIS GUY WANTED TO PROTECT
HIMSELF.
THE QUESTION I ASK BASED ON
THAT, BECAUSE THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT ELEMENT TO THIS CASE,
DO WE FEEL SAFER?
AGAIN, I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER.
RIGHT NOW I DON'T.
I HOPE I'M PROVEN WRONG.
IF I'M PROVEN WRONG, I'LL BE
BACK AROUND THIS TABLE, AND SAY
YOU GUYS ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
>> IT'S NOT A POPULARITY
CONTEST, WHEN SOMETHING IS
GUARANTEED BY THE CONSTITUTION.
YOU SEE, IT'S NOT WHETHER OR NOT
WE AGREE.
>> EVEN THE CONCURRING
OPINION --
>> THEY SUPPORT HELLER AND
McDONALD.
I DON'T WANT TO GET INTO THE --
>> CAN I POINT OUT ONE THING.
>> YEAH.
>> SOMETHING HAPPENED IN THIS
SHOW FOR THE FIRST TIME IN THE
HISTORY OF ALL OF CABLE
TELEVISION, A PANEL SAYS "I
DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER."
YOU NEVER HEAR A PANELIST SAY
THAT ON ANY SHOW.
>> I WANT TO ASK THIS, THE
ARGUMENT THAT YOU'RE READING
TODAY, FROM PEOPLE UPSET ABOUT
THIS DECISION, JUST WATCH UNTIL
THE DOBBS DECISION IS ANNOUNCED,
AND THEY WILL BE MAKING THE
OPPOSITE CASE TO TRY TO MAKE
THEIR CASE THERE, AND THAT WON'T
MAKE SENSE.
>> OOH